هزه ارتداديه منذ بدايه الهزه سته على
فاصله عشره التي وقعت عند السواحل التركيه
والسوريه الان منذ خمس دقائق لازالت
الهزات الارتداديه ولكن بدرجات متفاوته
كان اكثرها السادسه
والاعشار وحده الكوارث التركيه وايضا
الحكومه التركيه تطالب من الناس ان يخلوا
الشوارع في المناطق المهضمه وفي المدن
التي هي بطبيعه الحال مهدمه هي غير غير
يتواجد بها الناس هي تطالب ايضا من
المواطنين الذين هم في المخيمات ان يفقوا
في مخيماتهم وتطالب ايضا ان لا يتجول احد
قرب هذه
بنايات او في الشوارع وهذا ايضا ما حصل
حتى انه كما نشاهد الان من مواطنين هم
ينقلون سريعا من بعض البيوت التي هي
بالطرف ابنيه من طابق الى هذه الخيام كل
الناس هي متسمره في عمليه ونشاهد ايضا كما
تشاهدين معي لانه في الواجهه هذه مجموعه
من مخيم كبير في الوراء ظهرنا هنالك مبنى
مؤلف من طبقتين فقط كان كمركز لوجستيا
وتحكم
لتقديم الاغاثه الان يخلى كليا من الناس
والمواطنين
والعدد من المواطنين يخرجون الى هذه الخيم
التي هي امامنا حركه السير في الشوارع
الرئيسيه في المدينه التي نحن بها هي
بالاصل معجومه ولكن الناس الذين كانوا
يتواجدون من متطوعين الى فرق اسعاف اخذوا
كل الشوارع المحيطه بشعاع بنايات العاليه
التي يمكن نشاهد الان ونسمع السيارات
الاسعاف التي تخرج من هذا المركز الاغاثي
الى داخل المدينه